In the first season of Game of Thrones, and
in the first book, Daenerys Targaryen walks
into a big fire, and comes out unharmed. Before
that, she says “fire cannot kill a dragon”.
This has led a lot of people to believe that
Dany, or all Targaryens, cannot be hurt by
fire. And this is not true. So, a bunch of Targaryens have been burned.
Dany’s brother was killed with molten gold.
Aerion Targaryen died after drinking wildfire.
Aegon V Targaryen and Duncan Targaryen died
in a fire at the Tragedy of Summerhall, though
we don’t know exactly what happened there.
And another Targaryen who is burned is Daenerys. Without
spoiling anything, in a chapter of A Dance
With Dragons, Dany is burned, leaving "Her
skin … pink and tender, [with] pale milky
fluid … leaking from her cracked palms [and]
her burns … healing". Daenerys Targaryen is burned, and is not immune to fire.
If you need any more proof, George R. R. Martin
himself has said several times that Targaryens
are not immune to fire. Quote: “TARGARYENS
ARE NOT IMMUNE TO FIRE!” Capslock his. “The
birth of Dany's dragons was unique, magical,
wonderous, a miracle”.
Another quote: “some fans are reading too
much into the scene in GAME OF THRONES where
the dragons are born … it was never the
case that all Targaryens are immune to all
fire at all times.”
One more – “no Targaryans are immune to
fire. The thing with Dany and the dragons,
that was just a one-time magical event, very
special and unique. The Targaryans can tolerate
a bit more heat than most ordinary people,
they like really hot baths and things like
that, but that doesn't mean they're totally
immune to fire”.
So, case closed, yeah? Targaryens are a little
heat-resistant – which explains why Dany
wasn’t burned by this bath, or this egg
– but the thing on the pyre was a one-off
and Targaryens are not immune to fire.
This has implications for R+L=J. Jon Snow
burns his hand at one point, and some people
take this to mean Jon can’t be the son of
Rhaegar Targaryen. But since Targaryens are
not immune to fire, Jon can still have the
blood of the dragon even though he was burned.
So yeah. Just wanted to clear that up, ‘cause
it’s a really common misconception. If people
repeat it, show’m these quotes. Thanks for
watching.